in other words what are the symptoms of
a gin
possession some common symptoms are mood
shifts and changes in personality
depression uncontrollable laughter or
crying epileptic convulsions a changed
voice like in those demon movies U
suddenly being able to speak a foreign
language that you didn't know before um
recurring nightmares and insomnia among
much
else now some of you might be thinking
many of these kind of sound like me so
am I possessed by a Jin probably not as
symptoms will also often include
religious aspects such as um negative
reactions to the recitation of the Quran
or the call to prayer or a general
abandonment of religious observances